so we've got a circle here this is my
circle does it look like a perfect
circle but we can use our imaginations
and let's say it's got a radius of let's
say the radius the radius of this circle
is equal to 3 meters my question or the
question we're going to answer in this
video is what is the area of this circle
what is the area and remember the area
is just how much space this circle takes
up on a surface or on this computer
screen that you're watching or on this
piece of paper so it's literally if you
wanted a carpet if this circle this is a
room it's how much carpeting you would
need to fill out this circular room
that's what the area is that is what the
area is now I'm not going to prove it to
you and we'll do that later but the area
for a circle it just takes on a fairly
straightforward formula and I want to
just get you used to applying that
formula so the area of a circle area of
a circle is equal to PI remember PI was
that number that fee people figured out
was the ratio between the circumference
and the diameter of a circle is 3.14159
keeps going on and on and on it's just a
number but it's a very magical number pi
times the radius squared pi times the
radius squared in fact another way of
defining pi you could even rewrite this
right here saying that the area over
your over your radius squared so this is
your radius so if you multiply the
radius times itself you can imagine that
would be that would be the area of a
cube that's like that that the ratio
between the area of this entire circle
and the ratio of this cube right here of
this cube right here that is the core
the square I shouldn't say a cube cube
would be if we went into a 3d but this
the ratio of these of the area of this
circle to this to this square right here
is also equal to PI that could be an
actually an alternate way of defining
what pi is and if you were to measure it
very carefully using there's thousands
of methods you could do it you would get
3.14159 and keep going on and on and on
but we're not going to delve too deeply
into that maybe one day I'll make a
whole playlist on pi but we just have to
know that the area is equal to PI R
squared so let's just apply the numbers
here so in our example the area is equal
to PI times 3 meters squared which is
equal to PI times 9 meters squared or
the conventional way to write this this
is equal to 9 PI meters squared
and remember 9 pi we the convention is
just to leave it that way but this is
the same thing as 9 times 3.14159 which
is probably going to be like 28 point
something meters squared just remember
this is just some number and it's not 9
it's actually closer to it's closer to
28 because it's going to be 9 times
3.14159 but we just leave it like that
and that normally will be good enough
for you say hey that is my area that's
my area 9 pi now let's go the other way
let's say I have a circle like that and
let's say that someone let's say that
the area the area is equal to 16 pi what
is the diameter what is the diameter
what is the diameter of that circle
going to be well we know that area is
equal to PI times the radius squared so
at least let's figure out the radius so
the area 16 pi is equal to pi times our
radius squared I'm just applying this
formula we're just going to keep
applying this formula over and over
again when we're dealing with area so
area which we've been told is 16 pi is
equal to pi times radius squared now if
we divide both sides of this equation by
pi we get 16 is equal to R squared and
then you take the square root of both
sides then you get 4 is equal to R I
guess r could also be equal to negative
4 but we're dealing with distances here
you can't have a negative radius or at
least in the world we're living in right
now just to keep things simple we just
want to keep our distance as positive so
let's say that this is this has a radius
of 4 now if the radius is 4 what is this
diameter
well the diameter is always going to be
two times the radius of this four we're
gonna have another four there so the
diameter is equal to it's equal to eight
now let's do a slightly harder one
that'll kind of compound some of the
other things that we've learned in the
past so let's say that I have a circle
here and let's say that its
circumference let's say its
circumference for intz let's say that's
its circumference is equal to it's equal
to 20 PI 20 pi and I want to know its
area I want to know its area so the way
you do all of these problems just figure
out everything you can given what
they've given you and then maybe you can
work out the thing they're asking for so
if I know that the circumference is 25
what do I know about its radius what we
saw in the last video that the
circumference is equal to 2 pi 2 pi
times the radius so if the circumference
is equal to 25 we could write that 20 pi
is the circumference is equal to 2 pi
times the radius now if you divide both
sides of this by pi those cancel out and
then if you divide both sides by 2 this
becomes a 1 this becomes a 10 or you get
the radius is equal to 10 which makes
sense right 2 pi times 10 is he going to
be equal to 20 pi so we figured out our
radius now we know that the area we know
that the area is equal to PI R squared
and lucky for us using the circumference
we were able to figure out the radius
now using the radius we can figure out
the area so the area the area is going
to be equal to PI times R squared R is
10 times 10 squared which is equal to pi
times 100 or it's equal to 100 pi just
like that so your circumference was 20
pi when you went around the circle but
your area of your circle is a hundred pi
and if I gave you units it would be 100
pi units squared that is your area right
there 100 pi anyway I think that's
a good initial exposure to the area of a
circle I'll see you in the next video